regardez ce que j'ai trouvé dans le
jardin un verre mais non pas celui ci un
lombric alors je sais tout le monde
n'aime pas ça mais ce petit animal joue
un rôle très important dans notre
écosystème sans lui on croulerait sous
une montagne de déchets organiques
les vers de terre dégrade cette matière
et la transforme en sels minéraux que
les plantes vont ensuite puisé avec
leurs racines et dont elles ont
absolument besoin pour grandir
les vers de terre trustent également les
galeries ce qui permet d'aérer le sol
faciliter l'infiltration de l'eau et le
déploiement des racines lors roulait
tellement important que beaucoup
d'agriculteurs ont renoncé au labour
pour préserver leur sol et je peux vous
dire que ça bosse sous nos pieds on
estime qu'il y a deux sens vers de terre
par mètre carré de quoi remplir une
belle capsules de déco fini allez on va
à la pêche aux idées 1
parce que pour la pêche à la ligne il va
falloir attendre un peu
nous sommes confinés mais en restant
lien si vous avez aimé cette capsule 2d
confiné n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce
bleus gens réalisent une nouvelle chaque
jour alors pour ne pas les rater
abonnez-vous et activer la cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain